l'autre actualité de l'Ensemble Vocal de
50 ans en niveline c'est ce spectacle
cœur baroque donc 6 avril toujours à
guilloncour auditorium de l'école de
musique alors vos chistes vont présenter
un travail qui a été mené avec des
musiciens de l' des instrumentistes de
l'école de musique et surtout des
chanteurs euh qui doivent évidemment
faire un énorme effort puisque ce sont
des adolescents qui relèvent le défi
depuis 3 ans de venir chanter avec nous
on les parinene sur des projets très
spécifiques les deux derniers projets
étaient plutôt de la musique on va dire
facile puisque petite suite québécoise
chanson francophone après Miss crolia
chanson Argentine et puis là bah le
grand saut c'est grand cœur baroque dont
l'alleluia de
Hendel quel regard vous portez sur le
travail qui est mené justement sur ce
travail là d'associer justement
l'ensemble vocal l'école de musique ça
fait partie des choses que je fais au
quotidien puisque j'ai aussi d'autres
coupables activités au au conservatoire
de de Versailles où je m'occupe un petit
peu de pédagogie et c'est c'est toute la
la la richesse je pense de nos
établissements quand ils sont bien bien
conduit et bien animé de l'intérieur
c'est justement de permettre à des
enfants de connaître une fultitude de de
style et d'époques différent pour
pouvoir après éventuellement s'il le
souhaite faire un choix mais on ne
choisit bien que dans ce que l'on
connaît donc la mission de ces
établissements quel que soit leur taille
c'est justement de permettre de
connaître de l'intérieur comment se
dérouler le spectacle du 6is quel quel
format quels sont les morceaux qu'ils
vont devoir bien et bien il va y avoir
des morceaux que l'on chante en commun
avec eux bien évidemment puisque le
parrainage le but du jeu c'est qu'il
chante pas tout seul tout seul il y a
des morceaux que les instrumentistes
vont par contre eux interpréter
totalement tout seul et chaque pièce va
s'articuler autour de différents thèmes
dont bien évidemment l'histoire des
saisons puisque la période baroque
c'était la grande la grande mode de
comme les quatre saisons de Vivaldi la
musique le chant se produire sur scène
être parrainé c'est quelque chose qui
marche très bien notamment la télévision
il y a beaucoup d'émissions autour de
tout ça qui peuvent exister est-ce
qu'ils sont nombreux aussi à à venir
frapper un petit peu à cette différentes
écoles et aussi à vouloir se se produire
sur scène parce que parce que c'est
devenu à la mode aussi mais ce n'est pas
qu'une histoire de mode je pense que
c'est une histoire de résonance la la
télé c'est quand même un outil très
utile et sur lequel les jeunes ont
évidemment un regard très affuté très
critique bien souvent quand ils viennent
nous voir pour nous dire j'ai j'ai
écouté The Voice je voudrais bien mais
mais je sais pas si je vais pouvoir ils
ont une un déjà une envie d'exigence et
ça c'est merveilleux parce qu'on peut
bien évidemment surfer dessus alors
c'est enrichissant pour eux est-ce que
c'est enrichissant aussi pour vous pour
les professionnels aussi de de voir un
petit peu ces générations arrivé et puis
de mais sans eux sans eux nous
n'existerons plus de toute façon voilà
c'est la la la musique n'est qu'un
passage donc il faut passer le flambeau
et c'est c'est c'est évidemment très
enrichissant pour nous cœur baroque 6
avril 18h 20h30 il y aura deux
représentations ça c'est une mission
aussi de l'ensemble vocal en ce travail
de pédagogie je vais juste insister sur
ça pour conclure toement oui puisque de
toute façon nous avons en plus mais on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler un atelier
aussi au théâtre de Saint-Quentin que
nous faisons qui est ouvert aux adultes
et cette mission pédagogique de
transmission est très importante dans le
cœur de décoristes de l'Ensemble Vocal
merci à vous deux rendez-vous le le 6
avril donc pour cet autre spectacle en
marche de cet hommage qui sera rendu
mardi prochain André chez did et vous
découvrirez notamment le travail que
vous avez pu mener sur vos compositions
merci donc à tous les deux